Tyler is where this Tyler is in Utah
hi Tyler welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up hey I was just calling had a
little predicament come up just recently
so my wife and I we have got two kids
and we are building a home in Idaho I'm
trying to save everything we can for a
down payment and so we moved in with my
in-laws actually last week and got hit
with about $7,000 worth of car repairs
and we wanted to know if we should what
what we should do it can't imagine a car
I would spend $7,000 now and that wasn't
the plan we weren't wanting that you did
you fix the car no no no that was that
was a bill that they had given to us and
I know I know this car worth not even
maybe five thousand so you don't spend
$7,000 on that car you sell it for drunk
yeah and so and so that was from here
we're wondering do we get a clunker yes
thousand dollars okay don't have any
money right and that and that's where
and I kind of grew up where parents had
those clunkers car after car after car
and they just sunk a ton of money into
it I did not suggest you do this car
after car after car I suggest you do it
right now because you're in the middle
of an emergency you live with your
in-laws near building house in Idaho
okay but when you get into Idaho you
better get your freaking act together
get yourself out of debt build your
emergency fund up and start saving up
for a better car yeah I drove a clunker
too but I drove it so I never had to
again yeah that's what you're doing here
and we've been pretty fortunate where we
don't have any debt and so that's why
we're trying to do everything we could
Sweden didn't you know buying a house is
a necessity and where we want to be but
then this car came along is like well in
a few years we want to get a car so we
could grow into it we've got two kids
right now I might have one or two more
oh you got a few years to save up for it
yeah okay so in terms of maybe thousand
dollars for a car mm what will be money
we've got right about six seven thousand
dollars saved right now oh good okay so
and we're hoping to have by the time the
home is done right about fifteen sixteen
thousand okay so I mean
I probably in that case and it sounds
sounds like your what's your household
income I'm 60 K yeah okay and two kids
two kids yep and a wife that works hard
at home taking care of them I'm sure I'd
spent I probably spent about three okay
in cash and here's the thing just a
reminder number one the reminder is is
this discussion is this is a temporary
fix 24 months from now you're living in
the other house and you're saving money
aggressively again only this time it's
to finish your emergency fund and above
that save up and move up in car okay so
we're not driving clunker to clunker
okay that's not the plan number one okay
number two given that that's the state
of affairs a reminder on how to buy a
three thousand dollar car you want to
buy an ugly car that is mechanically
reliable yeah I do not care about the
aesthetics if this a three thousand
dollar car should be a car that you need
to give a name to old blue big red the
big bomb I don't know give a name to it
and the kids can call it that and the
kids will remember having that car when
they were little for two years when mom
and dad were saving money after they
bought the new house okay but you're
looking for something has low miles in
his incredible mechanical condition and
I don't give a rip about the sex appeal
sex appeal and three thousand dollar
cars do not go together there's enough
they don't even go in the same sentence